Hello Freak bitches.
So tell me about your heart attacks if
you can't show me the video.
Yeah.
Uh,
so basically,
yeah,
I uh,
I was,
wow,
I think it was 25.
Um,
I was on a ski trip.
My fraternity brothers were in Park
City,
Utah.
Yeah.
Park City and uh,
we've just been partying.
I,
uh,
I met this chick in the lyft line,
ended up getting her number and it went
to the bar and I got like everybody shit
face.
It was like $300 bucks or I'd cut the
whole bar drunk.
We were having fun.
We go back to her house or banging until
like seven in the morning or six in the
morning and then I get a call,
like I just showered.
I was like,
just started sleeping on my buddy's
like,
hey,
it's the last fucking day.
Like we're going like,
let's ride.
And I was just like,
ah,
fuck it.
All right.
Sure.
So I took a shot at drink of coffee,
got my shit on,
went out.
We reached out to booze.
Yeah,
shot of Tequila.
Jesus Christ.
Wow.
Was like,
fuck.
I mean,
you know what I mean,
if you don't,
if you keep drinking,
you don't get hung out.
Right?
So I'm just like fuck it.
So when wrote all day and then that
night,
I don't know,
I don't know if it was like a stomach
flu or what,
but I was just like puke in and I just
like felt like shit and I just like
couldn't keep anything down.
I remember I paid like the hotel guy
like 100 bucks or getting a bunch of
gatorades.
It couldn't even like leave my room.
So next day go to the airport and I knew
that if I got Nivea I would feel better
because I've like had some,
you know,
when you get dehydrated that's usually
like the root of most of your problems.
So I just ended up buying an ivy from
this medic because the guy's like,
well if I hook this up to you,
you know,
like you're not gonna be able to fly.
And I was like,
dude,
like you know,
I gave him a bunch of bullshit out.
Scott,
you know,
fucking medic from the military and you
know,
this and that and I qualified to do
that,
you know,
and it was a guy in a fucking salary,
the bag,
you know,
basically just gave it to me.
I hooked it up myself,
like on the plane.
Had you ever done this before?
Yeah,
we did it a couple times when we were in
buds,
like if we went out drinking or whatever
and uh,
and we had to train the next day or this
is a commercial flight or a private
flight?
Commercial.
Yeah,
commercial flight.
You Hook up an IV bag?
Yeah.
Well in the bathroom like,
yeah,
before I got on there.
Right.
So I go in the bathroom,
like hooked this thing up,
you know?
Yeah.
You ain't gotta wait like an hour.
Right.
So I'm like,
what else are going to do is I fucking,
you know,
Hook this thing up and start feeling
better.
Go to Vegas.
How long did you let it drip in there?
For?
Probably 20 minutes.
I was just like,
you just locked the bathroom and just,
he had just hooked it up and fucking
hold on the door.
Hey Dude,
I'm going to take a shit.
Nah,
no.
It was like,
no,
I'm pretty sure it was in the airport.
I mean it's just been like fucking 11,
12 years.
But yeah,
it was,
I think it was a,
it wasn't,
uh,
wasn't on the plane.
It was like in the airport of thing,
like in the bathroom.
Yeah.
And so,
you know,
I just,
and so I sort of sketchy started.
Yeah,
super sketchy.
So I don't even know if I used alcohol
is such a scumbag.
So I,
uh,
I get to Vegas,
I'm like feeling a little bit better.
I'm just like,
I'm such a sick of like wanting to go
gamble,
right?
Like I should've gone and like checked
into.
Oh yeah,
I did check into my real,
I should have gone to sleep or no,
I like go gamble,
play poker all fucking night.
I'm like gambling,
you know,
poker,
stressful and this and that.
My buddy comes to me,
he's like,
Hey,
you know,
we've got these strippers,
like let's go to the Strip club.
I got ecstasy and all this drugs.
And I was like,
fuck,
all right,
fine.
You know,
I was like winning a poker.
Sure.
So we started getting fucked up,
go to the Strip club and um,
and I asked the,
you know,
and I asked the first check that like
came over.
She's like,
oh,
like do you want them lap dances?
I'm like,
no,
like I haven't slept in like two days.
Like I just want to get my dick sucked.
Like I give you $500 bucks,
right?
Segmenting.
And she's like,
no,
like,
you know,
like I'll fuck you.
And I was like,
no,
like,
you know,
I was like,
I don't really want to fuck you,
I just want to get the blow job.
And she slaps me like [inaudible] BC.
She's like offering to fuck me for free.
And I said No.
So she's like,
oh,
says you slapped me in the face,
right?
I go and I was like,
Damn.
And I was like,
and then this and the next check comes
up and I like offered to the same thing.
I was like,
Hey,
like I'll give you 500 bucks or
something ridiculous.
Like I don't really want any lap dances.
She's like,
well,
you know,
I'm down to hang out,
and uh,
and,
you know,
I can get off.
And I'm like,
fuck,
I'm just like,
wow,
this sounds like she's gonna want me to
bang her.
I'm like,
I don't want to get slapped again.
I was just like,
okay,
like,
you know,
get your shit loading.
Let's get Outta here,
let's go to party.
So I talked to my buddy,
I'm like,
Hey,
like I need it,
you know,
I need a bag or some kind of Dick pill
or something,
you know,
and I'd never taken by Agra.
So I didn't really know the dosing or
whatever.
So he gives me the 100 milligram one,
which is like for fucking,
if you don't know anything about,
you know,
the address for like geriatrics,
right?
Steve Business thing,
I take the whole thing,
I don't know,
like a minute goes by and I'm like,
the fucking thing isn't working,
but I know I'm all coked up.
I think they did.
It seems like it's bedded our right
guys.
Like it hasn't been enough time to give
me the fucking give me another pill and
uh,
so no.
So he said,
he's like,
no,
I'm like,
give me the fucking thing.
So it gives me another user only take
half.
He's like,
don't,
you know,
don't take this.
And so anyways,
so I'd take another half,
wait like five minutes,
do some more blow.
And I'm like,
oh my Dick's not hard.
Like the girls aren't even around,
like I have no sexual esteem is no even
reason for my Dick.
The yard.
Right.
But it's like in my mind I'm like
overthinking it,
which makes it worse.
Right.
So like fuck it.
So I take the other half,
so now I'm like 200 milligrams into this
fucking bag or which is like,
you know,
double the absolute Max from what you
know.
Some guys have to get their Dick
drained,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
we'll get to that,
so go back to my hotel and I'm like,
fucking banging this shit out of this
girl.
Like,
you know,
I mean I got like veins coming out of my
head.
I'm sweating profusely and I'm like
doing blue.
I'd fucked her for like maybe like 45,
50 minute.
Like it wasn't not pleasurable at all.
This was like work,
right?
I'm just like.
And after like,
fuck man,
I think it was like 50 minutes.
I just like,
I had to quit.
Like I was just like,
I just,
you know,
I just knew there was zero chance of me
coming and I was like,
punished this chicken up and I'm just
like.
And I like didn't like I was tired of
when the bathroom took a cold shower,
my dick,
like go down.
Like I and I ordered some room service,
ended up like tucking it up into my
waist.
And um,
because like there's just no going down
with this bucket thing.
Right?
So ether room service I think.
Oh yeah.
Then I actually ended up taking a value
in,
went to sleep,
Bangor again,
woke up,
went and ate some Mexican food.
I was like betting on the sports game
and I started getting like this pain in
my shoulder and I didn't really know
what it was,
is like kind of just felt like a,
like an ache.
So started doing pushups that didn't
really make it feel any better.
And I was like stretching my arm.
I was like trying to sleep,
but I couldn't even lay on that side.
I'm just like,
what the fuck?
Like heart attack never even entered
into the realm of possibility of shit
that could be wrong.
Me,
right.
Like fucking 25 I guess like shoulder
pain.
Like wow,
you know,
I,
I had no idea about having a hard day.
So call my mom tardy at the family
doctor on the phone.
She calls this dude up and I'm like
getting like kind of shorter breaths.
I'm like fuck.
So I just hang up the phone and I find
out the hospitals like 10 minutes away.
So I'm like,
fuck it.
I'll just get a cap,
be faster.
I should have got an ambulance,
but I got a cab,
you know,
note to self,
always get an ambulance if you got any
shit because I got the cab.
I was in the waiting room for like 50
minutes.
I pulled out like 10 grand on my pocket.
I told the Lady,
I was like,
I'll give you 10 grand.
Let me talk to the fucking doctor.
Like something's wrong.
I don't know what's wrong,
but I know something's wrong.
Anyway,
she take the 10 grand,
fuck no,
let me sit in the fucking waiting room
and like 30,
40 minutes go by.
Finally could see my doctor.
He's like,
Holy Shit,
like you're having a full blown heart
attack all this stuff and giving the
Nitroglycerin and I call my dad and my
mom was like,
you know,
telling my mom,
I'm like,
I'm thinking I'm fucking done.
Right.
And because this has been going on for
awhile and I'm like having a hard time
breathe in.
I'm like in pain.
And so they gave me the nitroglycerin
right?
And I start feeling better.
They do an angiogram or whatever where
they check out the heart.
That said there was no damage.
Parents come out the next day,
I have another one and I'm like.
And I tell the doctor I'm going say.
And then my doctor was Conrad Murray
too,
by the way,
which was Michael Jackson,
Dr Guy that smoked him and the craziest.
I your talk it.
And the spookiest thing about the whole
deal was my grandfather had the same
doctor in the same motherfucking
hospital exactly one year prior and
died.
So I'm just like,
you know,
this is not looking good for the home
team.
This was before he killed Michael
Jackson is asked to write sound like,
you know,
fuck,
I'm just in the hospital.
So I call my dad.
I'm like,
I'm having another heart.
I tell the nurse and they're like,
no,
like your thing looks fine.
I call my dad.
I'm like,
there's something wrong with dad,
like comes down to the hospital and sure
enough,
like I'm having a second,
like minor heart attack.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
So they do a bunch of tests and say my
heart's fine and then they ask you for
like the list.
So I got to like give them the list of
my ex girlfriends there.
My Mom's there,
my dad's there,
and I'm just like,
started off with like,
oh well,
you know,
the smoking the pot.
And he's like,
well,
you know,
like,
you better tell us like,
what you've been like,
it's important.
We need to figure out what's going on
with you.
And I'll say,
ah,
and you know,
I did,
you know,
I did some,
ecstasy,
cocaine and like,
my dad like looks over at me like,
what the fuck,
you know,
my dad like Super Square and um,
anyway,
so then I was like,
yeah,
I think it took some Viagara.
My girlfriend's like fucking rioting
now.
And he's like,
how much?
I'm like,
200 milligrams just like,
what is twitter?
I'm like,
I don't fucking know.
It's a good thing,
you know,
seemed like water,
like that's like an insane amount.
Like.
Anyway.
So I,
uh,
I,
I ended up staying in the hospital for
like four days.
I actually fucked my girlfriend in the
hospital with all these cords and crazy
shit.
Jesus smoked a joint in the hospital
thing.
I fucked her,
like I had a buddy of mine bringing like
wine coolers in Chinese food,
I think the worst patient of all time.
Right.
And somehow like,
you know,
I'm so give me all these fucking pills.
I got to take their telling me like I
got to take these pills for the rest of
my life for the rest of your life.
That's what they said.
And I was just like,
after like three days,
like I fucked my girlfriend eight,
the Chinese food.
I was like,
okay.
I'm like back to being invincible again
through all the shit is a heart attack.
Exactly.
I've heard that,
that phrase.
But what is the exact medical thing
that's going on?
You know,
for guidance had to.
I should know.
Um,
I don't know,
I think it's just like basically when
your heart's not getting enough oxygen
or something or um,
I don't know,
it's just not functioning properly.
Usually there's like a.
yeah,
there's like a blocked artery.
There's something and I think like coke
is a,
is a vasoconstrictor,
whatever,
so maybe like constricted my veins.
So there wasn't like an Agra visal
dilator,
so does shouldn't have bounce it out,
I think,
but I don't know.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
I don't really know the science behind
it,
but I know that like coke and wag or I
don't think you're supposed to make
some.
I Dunno it.
Wow.
I mean,
I know I did a lot of both.
Should've canceled out,
but I guess it didn't.
I guess what the body was like so
confused it going.
So a director is like,
fuck,
you had to shut down.
I don't know.
Wow.
That's fucking terrifying.